hello everybody welcome to rational
science
and we have a great day today
uh
hopefully um
we make it swift
anyways uh today's uh 21st anniversary
of
um 9 11.
okay
you can say it's practically history
what what happened it's like you know
talking about world war one now
and but there is something you may want
to consider today and it doesn't matter
if you think that it was done by george
bush or bin laden okay
uh we're not talking i'm going to talk
about the
uh
who and why
i'm going to talk about a different
subject and and this is especially about
this which is considered by those who
have investigated
9 11 to some degree right uh they
consider the especially those who
believe it was an inside job
um
they believe this is the uh sore thumb
the um
you know the the um
called uh the specific thing that um
really points that 911 was done by the
government and it's a world trade center
seven okay the way it came down and so a
lot of people have problems with that
and here this is what it looks like okay
you're gonna see world trade center
seven on the left and a regular uh
demolition
as they think uh world trade center
seven was
uh on the right okay so you'll have a
side-by-side comparison i just want you
to look at it we're gonna look at
physics for this okay
and here it is okay the one on the left
is world trade center seven from
different angles
and on the different uh
normal demolitions okay that's what
you're seeing there okay so a lot of
people say well you know it looks like
world trade center seven was a
demolition and the problem was that um
you know it takes several months to
bring down a
uh building through demolition such as
world trade center seven so it couldn't
have been done that same morning
couldn't have been done that same day
to bring it down like that if it was a
controlled demolition it would have take
months to put all the explosives in
place
so now what's the issue
well the issue is that um
you know we have um
on that day
what
is interesting for me and uh something
you may want to ponder if you want to do
an investigation a serious research on
the subject
is
why weren't
physicists
okay
so-called physicists mathematical
physicists why weren't they
interviewed
uh on that day and days uh subsequent to
that you know why weren't some of these
big-name
physicists
uh question about what happened on that
day
for example um
imagine they would have asked uh stephen
hawking okay stephen hawking they would
have said look uh
how did that building come down and he
would have done maybe his experiments
his
measurements his calculations and what
if just a what if right he would have
come back and said
that was a demolition that was that
building was demolished
through explosives
and what i'm talking about here is a big
name stating that okay big name like
stephen hawking was at the time
and he would have said that you know it
would have uh caused quite a bit of a
stir
and if they would have interviewed some
other people you know uh here here's a
list of some of them okay like if they
would have interviewed any of these
people okay
uh hawking cox
uh carol uh
green suskin kaku you know any of these
folks they would have interviewed them
said what caused
the building to come down and any of
them or several of them would have said
that it was done by
uh demolition
you know that would have been a
different uh world
and i'm sure they would have been
visited
by someone saying you know we we
encourage you to change your mind you
know
to recant
uh but it would have made a big
difference if a big name several big
names
uh in mathematical physics uh would have
said you know uh this what i think
happened even if they would have said
the opposite even if they would have
said yeah that was brought down by
debris by fire by whatever okay it
doesn't matter
but uh none of them were interviewed
because you know if they would have
interviewed them in a way they're
putting them on the spot okay they're
saying look we want you who are an
expert in physics right to tell us how
that building came down right
that never happened not with any big
names okay now some people might say
well you know they're not experts
um
in demolitions they're not experts in
what happened maybe you got to look at
i don't know engineers architects
detectives
but you know that's wrong a physicist
real physicist a genuine physicist
should be able to tell you how a
building like that comes down
okay
it's got to have
some good idea of how it comes down
and the funny thing again is that they
didn't interview any big-name people
they interviewed a lot of these uh
nobodies that nobody knew anything about
especially people from the nist
who uh
you know i don't know if they were even
physicists
you know so the question is why did they
interview some big names
and yeah i think uh what would have
happened if they did interview some
someone some big shot some big name guy
up there
it would have made a big difference you
know and
that never happened
um especially on building seven you know
so
something for you to ponder in addition
to
all the other stuff that you research
out there
anyways um
some people ask me what is this channel
about
you know uh how do i what do i propose
for um for gravity for electricity
magnetism etc right
and i have a
series of five videos which are at the
top
there of the um of this channel
and also my other channel
bill gatey
and uh it's called introduction to the
rope hypothesis so those people who want
to
get an introduction of what we propose
here in exchange to what they propose
out there
the establishment other dissidents etc
this is what we propose you can get a um
your learning curve very quite steep
here you know get a very quick
introduction to each one of the subjects
light electricity gravity etc okay
so in
they're uh anywhere from i think three
to six minutes all of them so if you
just want to get a snapshot and get an
idea what the channel is about that's
where you have to go some people have
asked me well you know what's your
theory and that's where you can get in
in general terms a uh
an overview and then you know you can
work further by asking questions looking
at some of the other videos but that's a
good place to start
um
what do we propose well in i'm just
going to go quickly over this and i'm
going to say that
what uh i'm proposing is that physics
above all physics
is kid stuff
anyone can understand physics
and i'm not talking about someone who
went to college or even the high school
i'm talking about anyone who's six years
old seven years old eight years old can
understand physics
okay
people say bill you're crazy uh we
cannot understand the universe we cannot
understand how some of these things work
and you're saying that a six-year-old a
seven-year-old an eight-year-old can
understand this normal one right not a
mathematical physicist but a
six-year-old yeah can understand it
quite easily
and you might say bill you're crazy what
are you talking about
and yeah because see
physics is really for kids and it
doesn't require that you really know any
math that you run any experiments the
issue is understanding okay
and here's an example sometimes i put
this example up here here's an example
okay look at this okay
someone asks you how did the window
break
and
i think anyone who sees that right there
in front of you you say well the window
broke because a brick went through it
someone threw a brick through the window
to the glass
very straightforward simple you know did
i ask you what was the energy the mass
what speed what was the force i didn't
ask you any of that i said how did the
window break
that's what i want to know that's you
know you broke my window i want to know
how it broke and you say well i threw a
brick through the window that's how
anyone would explain that very
straightforward okay
now someone asks uh here you know how
did the pulley come up
or uh i mean how did the box come up and
you say well you know i um
listen here
uh
i tied it around a rope
the rope around the pulley and i pulled
on the rope someone pulled down the rope
and that's how the box went up
so if you want to know what caused the
box to go up you just look at this you
say well you know i think everybody
would answer the same thing say you know
the box went up because someone pulled
on the road and the box went up that's
it
very simple a six-year-old
seven-year-old eight-year-old for sure
can tell you you know what what he's
staring at there that's all we're asking
we're not asking how much did the box
weigh
did you uh use so much force was there
so much energy involved on the rope etc
none of that we're just asking how did
the box come up okay very
straightforward stuff
and again if you're going to answer
questions of mechanisms of how something
happened there you have very simple
stuff that even babies
almost you know making i'm not going to
go as far as babies but certainly a
seven-year-old an eight-year-old can
tell you how something happened okay
and uh here's another example okay here
the spoon falls to the floor
okay now you say well how did the spoon
fall to the floor
and now people go
nuts they go bananas they go crazy
they say i have no idea how the spoon
fell to the floor
and you know there is really no
difference between what you're staring
at there and what you just saw okay
let's put them all three together see if
we can find out if there's any
difference here okay
uh here you have the the three you know
for to compare you've got a brick going
through a window you have uh the pulley
pulling up the box and you have the
spoon falling into the floor
if i ask you how did the box come up you
have an answer if you i asked you how
did the window break you have an answer
now you're saying you don't know how the
wind how the
spoon fell to the floor why it always
falls to the floor why didn't fall to
the sky
you know and the only difference here
between these three
scenarios
is that you cannot see the object that
is in contact with the spoon
that is the only difference
other than that you know everything else
should be straightforward
and so the the issue here is that we can
if we can make
the invisible objects that mother nature
uses to create that magic of the spoon
falling down without apparently anything
coming in contact with it if we can make
the real the objects that are causing
that visible
uh maybe it would be like the other two
there wouldn't be any difference okay
people would say oh that's how easy it
was you know a um an eight-year-old
would be able to answer the question
and it turns out here we are three
thousand years after
you know the greeks and other people
started looking at these things
and not a single mathematician single
scientist so-called scientists on earth
can answer that question how did the
spoon fall to the floor and it's very
simple you know here
here we have a pencil i always use the
pencil again
and you let go of it falls to the floor
and you say what came in contact with
the pencil
okay it just falls by by magic always to
the floor
now in in the case of pull you know in
the case of the brick going through the
window you can answer but you cannot
answer the question which is the same
thing essentially okay it's the same
type of
mystery the only difference is that you
can cannot see what is causing the spoon
to fall to the ground
that's the only difference
so what we do here is uh you know we
we do things with objects
we try to visualize and we we try to
visualize the objects that are causing
the especially the effects that we
cannot answer those
you can call them invisible intangible
objects that cause
these magical phenomena okay that we
cannot answer today or the
mathematicians cannot answer today
and what's the difference well the big
difference it comes down to this and
it's got to do with the definition
mathematical physics essentially
uh
works with two definitions okay of what
a thing is what an object is what a
mediator is and there you have them the
first one is uh and both of these are
taken out of
the wikipedia
uh
the first one is that which you can see
or touch
okay so everybody thinks that an object
is that which you can see or touch
that's what it is in
everyday
uh language and everyday notions that we
have and so that people carry those
notions those definitions into physics
and say well it's that which you can see
or touch and the mathematicians
essentially use these two definitions
and that's why they insist on
experiments because they can
see and touch something in the lab
what they cannot see or touch are the
invisible intangible objects things that
are causing some of these effects such
as gravity okay
the other one is object is a collection
of matter
well you know those are irrational
definitions because a chair is yeah a
collection of atoms but that's not you
don't think of every object that you
look at as a collection
of particles or units or whatever
you know you see sylvester the cat on tv
right
and that's a cartoon
and so that's an object right
uh thing
that you're seeing there and you say
it's a collection of
matter
is that what sylvester is no a cat any
cat the word
cat
is not a collection of matter
uh that's not what an elephant is that's
not what a table is that's not what a
cherry is that's not the notion
that comes through your mind when you
see any kind of object you don't say oh
that's a collection of matter that's a
collection of atoms for example
no uh a chair is what you're pointing to
that thing that's in front of you that's
a chair and so if you want to teach you
the language your language to
an extraterrestrial klingon comes to
visit the planet you don't say well a
chair is a collection of matter
and a table is a collection of matter an
elephant is a collection of matter no no
you say that's a that's a table that's a
chair that's an elephant that's how you
do it you point and you name
that's how it works
and so yeah uh what did you point to
some kind of shape something that's in
front of them okay some contrast there
and so yeah every object in the universe
whether 2d or 3d
has shape it's a universal property
all objects have shape right if you can
think of an object that doesn't have
shape i'd really like to hear about it
okay
so that is the scientific definition of
the word object we can use it
consistently
but we can't use the other two
consistently in any way shape or form so
those two definitions we throw in the
trash can okay those belong in ordinary
speech you can use them there but don't
bring them into science they have no
place in science especially in physics
okay so how do we explain gravity well
again we are going to make the invisible
objects that mother nature uses to do
gravity we're going to make them visible
so that you understand the mechanism so
so you can imagine visualize how mother
nature is really doing this without you
seeing
you know these mediators that she uses
you know she's bringing something down
and you don't see the things that are
hooked onto the thing that's coming down
you just see the thing coming down the
visible one but you don't see the
invisible ones and so we make them
visible and here it is here we have um
an astronaut coming down to earth okay
and we're making the objects that are
bringing him down to earth
visible and you see those lines there
and we're saying that every atom in his
body every single one right we're not uh
i didn't include all the
lines that are connected to every atom
in his body to every atom on earth all
we're saying is that every atom in his
body is connected to every atom on earth
and so the farther away the uh astronaut
is the less he weighs why because all
the
these lines come together as a single
coaxial
and as he approaches the earth you know
they fan out and so that's what we're
showing there that's what's bringing him
down that's the explanation for the
acceleration of gravity and that matches
perfectly with
newton's famous equation
the one you see on the top
weight is a static concept so it's going
to be location specific okay
and uh what we're saying is the number
of independent ropes those are the what
those lines represent here you see the
ropes i've drawn the same thing a little
uh you know zoomed in with my telescope
here and there you see them okay so what
we're seeing is that the
uh astronauts being uh connected to the
earth by all these ropes as he
approaches the earth the ropes fan out
okay
and
there is an acceleration because at
every
location closer to the earth there's
more and more
of these electromagnetic ropes very thin
extremely thin ropes intangible
invisible right that are
getting farther and farther away from
each other and you see the fellow fall
down
towards the earth
okay and uh this is more or less the
mechanism here okay
uh
i put it up here give me a second here
there it is okay so this is what's
happening when two objects are very very
far apart the ropes superimpose and you
have uh very little gravity okay gravity
is almost inexistent because it all the
ropes form a single coaxial so to speak
but as one object approaches the other
the ropes fan out that's what you're
seeing also on the left with the
astronaut falling to earth
and that's what's calling cause causing
i'm sorry the acceleration of gravity
okay so that is the explanation we give
for gravity okay
and uh yeah we do it with what we call
the electromagnetic roads we they are
invisible and intangible they have shape
but they are invisible and tangible they
don't have the property of being seen or
touched by humans okay
and uh
and here is justification for that here
you have again i'd like to show mr
mueller from uh berkeley university and
he says every atom on earth is pulling
on every atom of you you're also pulling
on it
and the only way you can explain that
statement those two statements is if
if something is connecting every atom
if you're not connected then how do you
explain what he just said there you have
no explanation for it okay so if every
atom on earth is pulling on every atom
of you and vice versa right
well then it's uh
very clear you know every atom is
physically connected to every other atom
the only reason
you don't see
you know the uh atoms that are connected
from the spoon to the earth is because
you know they are invisible and
intangible objects because an object is
not that which you can see or touch an
object is that which has shape
okay so
this is the train of thought this is how
we explain it in this site in general
terms you can see some of the other
videos and see them in more detail
okay we have a
seat situation with uh the etheris a lot
of these people have
sent me questions and comments i'm not
going through well i'm going to go
through all of them because there were
too many that's that's the issue but
hopefully today i'm going to answer a
lot of their questions they're going to
see some of their questions being
answered there or at least what the
issues are okay hopefully they have
enough intelligence to understand what's
being put in front of them okay
and the first thing you need to know
about an ether is is he's just pretty
much like a an electric universer
a thunderbolter
and uh what is a thunderbolt or an
electric universer well he's a person
who explains gravity for example you
know with electricity
he thinks uh gravity is really
electricity or some form of electricity
in fact they do not believe or accept
gravity at all they say even gravity
is ultimately an electrical phenomenon
they will all say that that's in their
books that's in their presentations
it's up to you to locate all that but
if you look there through there through
the videos through the books that's what
you will find electricity is
gravity is electricity electricity is
gravity there is no difference in fact
they don't think gravity exists at all
it's all electricity okay
and uh what's the problem with that well
the problem with that is they never
define the word electricity okay and so
here's uh we have this electric
universer and he says uh yeah it's um
electricity but what he will never tell
you is what electricity is he cannot
define the word electricity
okay this is the issue and i went
through that a couple videos ago okay so
the issue is these people have no idea
what electricity is in fact even worse
later on they tell you it's the flow of
electrons and what they're using is the
quantum model of you know the planetary
model of the atom they're saying the
atom is this little ball in the center
called the proton and a little bead
known as the electron that goes around
it or somewhere around the proton
somewhere in the region
an orbital or whatever and the way the
electric universe
visualizes electricity is the flow of
beads this electron bead that goes from
atom to atom
okay so
they say it's the flow of electrons but
then they say it's current and then they
talk about the flow of current
and so on so they have all these
contradictions their language is not
correct they're not their language is
not precise at all
and the aetherius are pretty much in the
same boat here's an etherist okay and
this is what they believe and they
believe that you know if you ask them
what is the ether they cannot tell you
what the ether is they have no clue
whatsoever
okay
some think of it as a fluid some think
of it as a bunch of particles in the
background or some think of it as the
same thing as space some say that no the
ether is within space
and so we have a lot of problems with
these people because they never uh can
tell you exactly what the ether is okay
and so that's where we start with the
ethers that they they have problems
defining defining or pointing because
you have one choice or the other you
either define the ether the word ether
or you tell us what it is by
pointing you know giving us a little
picture of the ether so that we know
what
you're talking about we need that what
okay what is a what an object a thing so
if it's a thing we want you to point to
it
point to an image to
to a statue
something in front of us something we
can see okay
so that we can follow your presentation
okay we can visualize we don't even need
to see it but you gotta describe it in
such a way that we can visualize it okay
and what these people do they don't do
that they want to define on the one hand
they talk about an object they use it as
an object on the other and that's not
allowed in physics okay not in not in
science
okay so um
here we have some of the
valid points that ethers make we have we
have to mention that
and the first point that they make is
that light requires a medium
and in that sense
i'm all with them you know 100 percent
with them yeah light requires a medium
if you're going to talk about the
traveling of light the speed of light
something traveling requires an object
because the definition of motion is two
or more locations of an object
so you have to have an object
that means it has to have shape
okay
the object has to have shape that means
that you cannot use a concept and say
i'm going to make a concept travel
now you can't make love tran uh travel
you can't make intelligence travel can't
make energy travel for example all these
things cannot travel
okay it's gotta be an object and for
that you gotta point to the object you
gotta say look that's a cat
and now i'm gonna show you how the cat
travels that we can all understand okay
but you cannot have a concept travel
okay and some people don't understand
that much and so ether is say
you need a
some kind of object
some medium and light it's got to have
that medium there okay in other words
light has to be something
it can't be a nothing that's traveling
and that's good uh but we have a little
bit of a problem because we have this uh
issue between ocean and fish
that's a problem with the etherist and
they confuse the ocean with the fish
here's an example okay here's a little
fish okay
and the blue stuff is the ocean fish is
the orange one right goldfish maybe okay
no problem we all understand that so
light can be the fish
okay but what's the issue the issue some
of these people say that
light does not need a medium through
which to travel
okay
well that's like saying
the fish doesn't need an ocean through
which to travel
that's not a problem okay let's get rid
of the ocean we have no problem with
getting rid of the ocean but if the fish
is going to travel it's going to do some
traveling hopefully the fish is a
physical object okay so we don't need to
talk about the ocean the medium through
which the fish travels okay
because if you go in there and you say
look um
you know
for example
the fish is nothing in other words the
fish itself is not a physical object
then you you would end up with something
like this you have ocean only
can you see the fish traveling there you
know i mean why can't you see the fish
traveling because you don't have an
object
so you you need to have at least an
object if you're going to talk about
light doing any kind of traveling and in
this sense the ethers are correct you
know you need that fish there if you
if you're going to talk about light
being something that travels through an
ocean
so the ocean the question is whether the
ether is the fish that is vibrating
there you know the the
wave perhaps a transverse wave
uh i don't care if that fish vibrates up
and down no problem but
that's got to be different than the
ocean you cannot say the ocean and the
fish are the same thing
and
the fish is just a vibration of the
ocean locally of the ocean okay that's
where the problem is with with these
etherist
the other issue we should mention is
that you know they're correct in saying
that the establishment you know the
mathematicians
um
they didn't really ever get rid of the
ether
and in this sense the ethers are correct
uh what the mathematicians did is
replace the ether with space-time with
uh the false vacuum
uh fields they like to use fields and
they say it's the vibration of the field
yeah that's a way of cheating they're
saying it's the ether but we don't call
it that
in fact um uh robert mclaughlin's uh
robert laughlin uh no uh nobel prize uh
he said you know
we never got rid of the ether but we
don't call it that because it's taboo
so in that sense the etherists are
correct uh the mathematicians never got
rid of the ether
okay and they just gave it all these
fancy names like space time and false
vacuum but they never got rid of the
ether okay
and so in that sense they're correct but
again we have to distinguish between
the fish and the ocean
that's a problem the etherists have
a lot of them have problems with they
can't distinguish between the fish in
the ocean you cannot say
a fish needs an ocean to travel through
we don't care about that get rid of the
ocean completely but hopefully the fish
if you're going to do any traveling even
if on land or in the air
or out there in space hopefully the the
fish is a physical object
it's a thing it's a medium itself okay
so saying that
uh
light does not need a medium through
which
to travel it's irrational
okay because we don't care about the
medium through which it travels we care
about light itself that had better be a
something if it's going to do any kind
of traveling because motion requires an
object you can't have motion without an
object otherwise what's moving okay so
this is the issue physics first and
foremost begins with objects you need an
object to do physics
okay so what are the problems with the
ether well here's a rundown of it okay
if i can get it up here
okay
this is a summary of some of the
problems that the aetherius have and
some of the action items that we require
of ether is anyone defending the ether
okay is it an object or a concept
it can't be both
god can be
a human you know with a magic wand you
know
i'm god sometimes you know
and he can make the universe waves his
magic wand creates you know the universe
no problem but god's an object has to be
a thing in fact uh michelangelo drew
drew uh painted you know god
sistine chap up there okay but if god is
a concept such as love
intelligence
well then we can't draw god we can't
make a picture of god okay
and so either god is a concept or god is
an object god cannot be both
when those people who say he's both or
none
all they're doing is evading the
question that's all they're doing okay
so god has to be an object or a concept
and the same thing for the ether ether
cannot be both either
ether is a thing
okay and you point to it and you name it
you say that's the ether there i'm
pointing it like you would point to a
chair or a rock or a tree
or ether is a concept and you say well
it's like intelligence it's like energy
is like a field you know you can use any
of those because all those are concepts
then you cannot use it as an object you
cannot use the ether as a paddle
uh in your
in your
dissertation you cannot say the ether
vibrates because there you haven't
defined it as a thing
you can say um you know
a rope vibrates up and down a string
you know a standing wave you can create
it with a string but you cannot have a
concept and move it up and down because
what are we staring at what's the
concept that's vibrating okay so this is
the issue you got to determine once and
for all if the ether is an object or a
concept that's the first problem we have
okay
and here's um here it is okay either
ether is a wave
that uh shiny thing you see on the left
that's uh gonna move up and down but
here we show it in a single picture so
that we can point to it and say that's
the ether that's what the ether looks
like okay so now the ether is an object
we can identify it looks something like
that you don't like that put your
picture of the ether there so that we
can see it in the same way otherwise
define it
and in which case it's not a thing
and you cannot use it as a thing in your
dissertation you say the ether is a
continuous fluid blah blah blah blah
blah whatever you want to define it as
we don't care okay so either you define
it or you make a picture of it that's
the only way to present this in science
so you have to choose okay you can't
have both you can't say well it's an
object
i can't point to it i can't show it to
you
um uh but let me do my theory and you
can't do it the other way around either
you can't say well it's a concept like a
spirit like an energy like
uh you know um
i don't know a field or a wave
uh but but uh you know i'm gonna move it
now you can't move concepts
so it's black or white yes or no on or
off you can't have it both ways okay and
these people want it both ways they want
to define it as a concept
like the electric universes they define
electricity then they move electricity
they say the current flows no the
current cannot flow because the current
was already flowing
it was already a dynamic concept
okay so here we have um
another issue which is
whether the ether is
equal to space or is not equal to space
is space and ether are these two words
synonyms perfect synonyms is space ether
in his uh ether space
or is ether contained within space like
if space were some kind of
container
okay
so we have to distinguish between ether
equal to space
and ether not equal to space and we have
a big problem there with the ethers
because you have all these ether is and
some say well it's equal to space the
other people say it's not equal to space
and here we have the two versions okay
the one on the upper left hand corner
there uh the wave
uh you know you look at that and say
well space is the black stuff and ether
is the bright stuff okay we all
understand that in that case ether is
not equal to space whatever you put
there we're saying these are two
different things otherwise if you say
the ether is space you got the situation
on the bottom left where
all of space and ether is the same thing
i painted it
light with a light color you can paint
it black if you want i don't care but
the point is there is no difference in
that case between ether and space
and one of the issues there again that
you have to be aware of is that if you
take this
bottom option you got to tell me whether
space is finite or infinite okay
if space is finite it's an object and in
which case you have to um you know show
me what's where it stops and what
continues you got to tell me what the
white stuff is
that gives shape to space which gives
shape to ether in other words ether has
space as a backdrop and space has
something else as a backdrop you got to
tell me what that white stuff is
okay that's the issue you can't you
can't even you can't even begin your
presentation until you solve these
problems okay on the other hand if you
say that space is infinite okay if
that's what you're going to use
uh well then we have a problem because
now you're you're essentially telling me
that space is not a physical object then
it's not a container you got to tell me
what is space
okay if it's not a container
it's not a thing because it does you
can't tell me what's outside of it
giving shape to space
then now you got to tell me what space
is in the alternative what is space you
got to define the word or tell me what
it is in fact you can't tell me that
what it is anymore because you already
said it doesn't have anything outside of
it
okay it's not finite so okay so if it's
infinite what is space in your theory
before if it serves as a backdrop
to
the ether okay
again you gotta resolve these issues
before you tell me any of your theories
so you got to spend two years
on the ether before you begin your
theory we don't care about your
theory for sure five seconds will do we
want you to spend two years on the word
ether
that's the question that's the issue
okay
okay so um
the other issue is whether space is made
out of a single piece or out of
particles i mean
what's the situation here okay uh are
you saying that space is
made of uh continuous
or people like to use the word
contiguous you know
are we saying it's made out of a single
piece that's the question
don't don't use any other words single
piece or made out of particles and here
you have uh
space with
the ether within space okay and as you
can see it's moving
so if it's flexible
are you saying that it's made out of
pieces out of parts is that ether made
of parts
okay
and one of the problems these people
have uh with this is that because i can
you i mean if you can if you want to
tell me that
it's made of a single piece but it's
flexible i have no problem
but the important thing here is that the
ether is that whole shebang the whole
bright spot the whole thing that is
throughout space and the earth is
somewhere in there and some in in within
that bright spot okay so
the ether serves as a backdrop to
everything okay and it's this thing
that's
everywhere around us okay that's how you
have to visualize this but what happens
these people say light is the vibration
of the ether
and what they do is they don't vibrate
the whole shebang the whole ether of the
entire universe what they do they want
to vibrate something locally like that
see they say see that's the ether it's a
vibration of the ether
no that's not the vibration of the ether
the vibration of the ether is the big
guy okay that's the vibration of the
ether if you're going to say that
there's a portion
of the ether that vibrates now we're
talking about something else we're not
talking about the ether you can't call
that little wave there at the ether okay
now you got to say look there's a little
tiny region
of the ether that is vibrating meaning
the ether is made of parts
okay because now you've chopped a little
segment off the big
ether and now you're moving that little
ether saying light is that little ether
that you see there the the transverse
wave or whatever the
you know the little worm there that you
see so we have to establish what the
theory is is the vibration of the is the
whole universe vibrating is that what
you're saying when you say that the
ether vibrates or are you referring to a
small portion a region of the ether in
which case you're not talking about the
ether now you got to use a different
term because you cannot confuse the
little
segment there the little region that's
vibrating you cannot confuse that with a
big region that's vibrating across the
universe if you're going to say that
light is the vibration of the ether
that's the big guy and hopefully that's
not light okay because you wouldn't be
able to explain anything with that and
you're saying the vibration
is uh you know this whole thing there
well i don't know
if that's light uh you got a problem
because you cannot tell me why i have a
little bit of light here and another guy
has a little bit of light over there and
you're saying those are the vibration of
the whole shebang of the entire universe
no what you're saying here is that
locally it's vibrating meaning that this
big shebang that you call the ether is
made of little parts
that's what you're implying that's
that's the logic there you got to fix
that you got to tell me which one is the
ether okay and again does the ether move
you know i mean you know
uh i think i've got it here
yeah uh well now these are this these
are the particles of ether you know if
if you're saying that the ether is made
of
smaller parts okay then that's what
you're saying what you see on the right
otherwise if you're seeing it's uh on
the left and again we only took a
picture of it you know snapshot so we're
seeing a single frame of the ether we're
not seeing it moving at all we're just
saying this is what the ether is that's
what i'm going to be vibrating and so
the question is you know is the ether
made of parts
does it vibrate does it vibrate locally
does it vibrate only across the universe
what is light if you say that
that it's the vibration of the ether
you got to identify the ether without
any doubt and that's where all these
people fail because they don't pay
attention to these
details these questions they don't even
research them they don't uh try to
rationalize them at all okay
okay so again is uh these are a region
of the ether
that's not the ether
you know you're talking about something
else then
and again if the whole ether is shaking
with respect to what you know if it's
vibrating or whatever
so uh all i can tell you is that um
the ether has all kinds of problems
and it's the uh what we call the
hypothesis which is the problem uh your
assumption what you're saying that the
ether is your you begin your
presentation by presenting the objects
and you're saying this is the ether okay
tell me what it is show me the ether
point to it and say this is ether that's
what i'm going to use throughout my
dissertation then we can follow your
your presentation we can understand you
okay if you instead decide to define the
ether and say look this is my definition
of the word ether find and you can't use
it as an object
concepts are defined objects we point to
and name we visualize so that someone
can follow our presentation know the
difference between an elephant and force
okay force is not an elephant you can't
say the the force moved the wall no no
the elephant moved the wall not the
force
okay and so you don't use words don't
use concepts as objects and if you're
gonna again you find the ether as a
concept you can't use it as an object
all these issues have to be taken care
of
before you begin your presentation
okay we got it so i hope that answered
several of the questions that people had
out there okay
okay let's move to the uh
subject of today which is hypothesis
what is a hypothesis and people say well
i know what a hypothesis is and if i
don't know i'll just look it up in the
dictionary
and turns out the dictionary doesn't
have a single scientific definition okay
so any word you find in the dictionary
for sure for sure is misdefined for the
purposes of science for the purposes of
physics
okay so this fellow asked me the
following he says uh or says your ropes
are only an assumption an idea a
hypothesis
and the answer is yeah
that's what they are it's uh it's called
the rope hypothesis
okay why because it's the object so you
know here here's my rope hypothesis okay
i point to the rope
i say this is called a rope
in any planet
in the universe we call this a rope okay
uh you can buy it at the hardware store
and we're saying that light
is mediated looks like this
if we had the eyes of god and we could
see what objects
mediate what object essentially mediates
light
this is what we would see we would see
something that looks like this a pair of
twine threads that's our proposal uh you
can think of it as dna
uh
helical pair of um strands
but they're real physical strands that's
the difference between this side and
everybody else in the world everybody
else use concepts
they say yeah like the electric universe
the other day uh talked about them and
said
they say uh it's the current two
currents which twine around
well current is not a physical object
you know and then you had uh nasim
haramin i talked about a couple weeks
ago and again he says oh this energy
that twines around no energy is a
concept you can't twine around energy
because it's not a thing
okay and you can't use any of these
concepts you have to use a physical
object we're saying no light is made of
two physical strands what is physical
physical is that which has shape that's
physical the strands have shape
but you cannot see or touch it that's
the hypothesis that's the assumption and
that's what this is saying oh this is
just an assumption yeah that's what it
is it's an assumption we have to start
with an assumption in order in order to
build the theory upon that assumption so
the theory is consistent with the
assumptions okay
but the problem is people don't really
know what an assumption is
that's that's really where it starts you
know
people think that assumptions what they
learned in um in high school
you know uh they think it's a theory
that they think it's already an
explanation a tentative
explanation okay
and so we look at some of these
definitions that we find out there for
the word hypothesis
and these are some i pulled out okay i
talked about this in the past i'll go
quickly through them uh one says it's a
purpose another one says it's your
question the question you're gonna ask
another one says it's a tentative guess
okay a hunch
okay
some say it's a prediction
okay that you make a prediction and
that's what a hypothesis is
uh others equate it with an assumption
but again what is an assumption
and people think they know what an
assumption is and they say yeah i know
what an assumption is but we'll find out
if whether they know or not
okay
an explanation that requires evidence
with some evidence behind it or without
some evidence
you know
[Music]
they talk about testing it
uh
it says a theory is provisional until uh
and it's only called it's until then
when it's provisional that's
a hypothesis okay
and again tentative theory another one
says it's data analysis they have all
these
notions which are not synonyms
and they call all these
hypotheses okay and this is where the
problem is
you know the
word hypothesis is used in so many
different contexts
and you wonder finally you know what is
this person referring to when he says
hypothesis but the main one is that
people think it's an attempt temporary
or tentative
explanation for a phenomenon something
happened they say well i think let me
guess
and he gives you a theory he gives you
an explanation he says that's an
assumption
i'm assuming that that's what happened
that's more or less the context
uh
but because of that because they have
all these versions right of what a
hypothesis is you ended up or the
mathematicians ended up with ridiculous
explanations for everything and here you
can see how they ended up with religion
essentially that's that's the bottom
line they ended up with all these
opinions
beliefs which
they pass through as facts as truths
and really what they're doing is you
know giving you their version of
religion that's all they're doing okay
here you see
one of the consequences of this says a
hypothesis is a proposition that
attempts to what explain
a set of facts
okay is that what it is just an
explanation a scientific law you know i
talk about laws is a hypothesis that is
what assumed to be
universally true
well when you talk about truth what is
true you're just giving me your opinion
because i have a different truth
you know one person thinks that god is
true the other one thinks that the
non-existence of god is is true
okay so everybody has a different truth
different set of facts so these people
talk about facts and truth as if you
know they've already proven in and you
have to accept it they shove it down
your throat
and i'm saying well i don't know i i
don't like your truth says well we've
already proven it
so that means i got to memorize it is
that what i'm supposed to do i can't
challenge it because a group of people
decided that
what is a fact and that it's true
because it's already been proven through
experiments and equations and who knows
what else
raising their hands voting for it
no we have a problem because we
shouldn't talk about truth and fact in
science
okay
evidence you know that's that's an
opinion what is evidence of uh your wife
cheating to you
is
evidence of the contrary to your
neighbor
so you know who's right well we have
different evidence we have different
facts different truths
so truth fact evidence knowledge none of
that plays a role in science whatsoever
science is explanations we explain
objectively so that you understand
you can then believe
any facts any truth you want right
and it says allah has good predictive
power so what
you know the the issue is there when
they talk about laws they're talking
about equations and because they have an
equation which they've already
determined through measurement they say
now we can predict using this equation
okay so you can predict that there's
going to be an eclipse tomorrow at two
o'clock because you measure the
uh
the
eclipses throughout time
and you know it's going to happen at
such and such time at such and such
speed
you know so you can predict
but that doesn't tell you for example
why
there is an eclipse or why uh
you know why the uh what causes an
eclipse
in other words that the fact that you
know that it's going to happen doesn't
tell you what's causing the eclipse
that's a different question altogether
okay so and if you can answer that
hopefully you
it means you're
going back in time and saying oh i know
it's going to happen i can explain
what's going to happen because
of my experience with this phenomenon so
that's no longer a prediction now you're
talking about an explanation now you're
talking about what happened not what
will happen you know that it will happen
that's a description a prediction that
so far you haven't explained why if you
can explain why now you're talking about
the past you're talking about something
that already happened that's why you can
explain why okay
anyways uh you can see here
that it's all believed they say
well-established laws
well-established by whom
and says that explains a group of
observations or phenomena you know again
um one thing is the explanation
and the other one is the belief in that
explanation maybe someone else has a
different explanation for that same
phenomena okay
not necessarily an eclipse but you know
for whatever you know could be different
explanation in fact even for an eclipse
you might find some guy on earth that
says well i think god
comes in front of the sun
and you say well no that's not what
happens at all i know for a fact it's
the moon that comes in front of the sun
that's why we have the eclipse and the
other guy will insist that it's god
that's god that stands in front and what
are you going to do
you're going to say he's an ignorant
yeah he's an ignoramus but i mean that's
what he believes in that's his set of
facts
that god stands in front of the sun
that's why there's an eclipse what are
you going to do kill him because that's
what he believes in
so again belief opinion we don't care
about not in science in science we don't
care
what we care about is the explanation
what is your explanation this guy says
the moon the other guy says it's god
great they have two different
explanations you now can believe in
whichever one you want
okay that's not science that's religion
the the scientific part is how do you
explain this phenomena
that's science okay
anyways uh broad acceptance broad
means that you have to swallow it
because a group of monks
you know have already determined
something for you now you have to
believe it because it's got broad
acceptance among the ruling classes uh
within the scientific community okay and
again uh you know they talk about
prediction they talk about authority
okay so this is what the word hypothesis
has taken us to because they think that
hypothesis is some kind of explanation
then a tentative explanation from there
proceeds to an explanation that has more
uh evidence
proof
knowledge whatever you want to call it
behind it
okay so now it becomes a theory
and if more people vote for it if if the
whole congregation votes for it now
becomes a fact now you have to accept it
because a group of monks have decided
that you know space time is warped and
you just have to accept it that that's
the explanation for gravity
and if you don't accept it well then
you're
in the old days they would have
crucified you killed you somehow
tortured you you know
inquisition today they just ban you they
just say well you're a crank
so
and you're outlawed from you know any
uh so-called scientific forum that's
that's how it's done today okay
and again in is
accepted you know completely accepted
and again all this has to do with belief
and not with science science is just the
explanation part tell me the mechanism
and i'll figure out on my own if i'm
going to consider it a fact for myself
uh truth you know
if your theory morphs into effect for me
that's the way it works
okay so here
let me show you that assumption is not
a theory and a theory is not an
assumption in other words the assumption
is not an explanation
and people say yeah because
i'm making an assumption that this is
how it happened
and that's
no that notion is what they've
introduced into science and they say a
hypothesis
is an assumption yeah correct but
because it's an explanation
no not at all
hypothesis assumption has nothing at all
to do with explanation so let's show a
couple examples so that you see why
assumption is not an explanation
assumption is not
let me assume that uh this is what
happened
no that's not an assumption so here
let's look at
some cases so that you can see the
difference between a hypothesis and a
theory between an assumption and an
explanation okay so here it is okay
in science right assumption is not an
explanation and here we have a couple of
examples okay
assumption a hypothesis right that's the
word that's a synonym of hypothesis
assumption
let us assume that planet vulcan right
for example exists between mercury and
the sun
that's just an assumption so far i
haven't explained anything i'm just
making an assumption what if
there's a planet there between the
uh mercury and the sun what am i trying
to explain with this assumption i'm
saying well the mass of vulcan might be
able to explain you know why mercury has
this perihelion shift okay why it has
this rosetta-like uh orbit it shifts
every now and then
okay so the explanation is that i'm
trying to get to right
is why
mercury behaves as it does that's the
explanation i'm giving you an
explanation for that
one what am assumption and i'm am i
making i'm making the assumption that
there is a planet
somewhere between mercury and the sun a
tiny planet some mass out there and
that's causing the the
mercury to go in in weird uh
orbits
okay so
the explanation here is i obviously
nothing to do with the assumption
let's look at another example which is
more typical what people have in the
back of their minds and that is
let us assume that the window broke when
a hard object struck the glass
now that sounds already like an
explanation people say oh you already
gave me an explanation you're saying a
hard object was what caused
the window to break
but see
that's not the explanation i'm getting
to that's not the one that i'm trying to
explain to you
it was an explanation which i'm now
converted into simply an assumption
okay i'm saying let us assume
that a hard object is what broke the
glass
i'm not giving you a theory of the heart
object breaking the glass i'm making
that as an assumption
okay and what am i really trying to
explain i'm trying to explain that it
wasn't johnny who hit the glass with his
baseball bat it was the dogs who jumped
through the window another hard object
okay so so the theory is not
the explanation i gave you as an
assumption
because that is not the target
explanation that's used and as an
assumption i'm just making that
assumption making believe
i'm asking you to make believe to make
that assumption that a hard object is
what broke the window that's not the
explanation i'm targeting the
explanation is
you know what caused it and it wasn't
johnny with his baseball bat it was a
dog who jumped through the window
okay so hopefully you can distinguish
that uh an explanation is not
an assumption at least in science in
ordinary speech people say well you made
an assumption and that's your theory no
that's not my theory that that a hard
object broke the window my theory is
that the dog jumped through the window
that's how it broke that's my theory
okay
and i use the other one as an assumption
okay so here we have
um
my definition okay this is the one for
hypothesis what is a hypothesis for the
purposes of science specifically for the
purposes of physics okay
science rational explanations
what what am i going to do i'm going to
explain
in a rational manner okay i'm going to
try to explain what a mechanism in the
case of physics right i'm going to
explain a a process what a phenomenon
okay i want to know the causes of that
phenomenon for this i have to start with
a hypothesis what did this file say says
oh it's just a hypothesis you wrote yeah
that's all it is it's this is a
hypothesis okay this is just an
assumption i'm saying let us assume
please make believe right that's what
we're saying that uh light is mediated
by a rope-like
architecture okay and so that's how
mother nature's gonna do all this stuff
according to us according to me here
okay
so we're saying that's that's the object
i'm presenting i'm saying what's the
object i'm saying it's a rope
yeah it wrote like mecha wrote like
entity it looks like this if we had the
eyes of god it's not this one that's not
the one you buy in the hardware store it
just has that configuration that's what
we're saying okay then we have to have
the definitions we we better have good
definitions especially for the word
object okay if you're going to use a an
irrational definition such as c and
touch for the word object well you're
going to have trouble because not all
objects can be seen or touched and then
if you say well let's go to the lab to
prove my theory well there's nothing we
can prove because we can't see or touch
the mediators of light and gravity
so you know you started out with the
wrong definition an irrational
definition of the word object and that's
why definitions are very important and
they are presented at the beginning of
your presentation that's part of the
hypothesis hypothesis includes the
objects the definitions and also the
statement of the facts does it include
the facts no absolutely not facts are
what mother nature knows for a fact
happened
she she knows exactly she's got that
piece of um video
all the frames that happen exactly and
she's got it filed in her cabinet the
problem is we have no access to that
cabinet it's already in the past you
know it's
she has this past cabinet everything
that happens falls into that cabinet so
she knows exactly what happened but we
don't we can only make an assumption and
so we call that a statement of the facts
it's your version of what you think
happened
okay first frames you present the
initial scene so to speak right and on
that you're going to build
your theory
okay and the theory is going to be you
know the
explanation
of some kind of
cause mechanism whatever okay a
phenomenon
so this is our version of what a
hypothesis is hypothesis is not
a theory as it is in mathematical
physics and in so-called science today
where they say look
uh hypothesis is just an untested theory
a tentative theory it's a theory that
has no
significant or any evidence whatsoever
behind it it's just like a temporary
guess
a starting point that's not what an
assumption what a hypothesis is
it's an assumption an assumption is not
an explanation explanation is what a
theory is
so please do not confuse hypothesis with
theory or with explanation
hypothesis an assumption okay it's
necessary in the scientific method
that's how we use it in this site so
when you come with your little birdies
from mathematical physics or you come
with your ideas from high school and say
well this is what it used to be over
there it was a tentative theory
you came to the wrong site okay we urge
you to
go to another site please
okay
okay uh we had our science critic and uh
he talked about energy
what is energy well this fellow thinks
he knows okay he says that energy is you
know something we all know what it is
more or less okay and so we had a couple
questions with the word energy let's
find out what he had to say about energy
here goes listen carefully
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal are
is energy a physical object or a
property of an object
and if energy is a property in other
words a mathematical concept
what sense does it make in physics to
say that you transferred a concept
energy is a property it's much like how
weight is a property things will have
weight but that doesn't mean that weight
itself is an object
okay
so the question is
is energy a physical object or an
abstract mathematical concept
okay
and if it's a concept
can you talk about moving a concept can
you talk about transfer of energy
transferring energy does that make any
sense to you
okay can you transfer a concept
that's the question okay so first we got
to determine if it's an object if it's
an object no problem you know like this
ball i can say you know uh can i
transfer this ball from this hand to
this hand yeah i can do that why because
it's an object i can see it moving i can
talk about transferring a ball in
physics okay in physics okay
and the question can i do that with
energy well i can if it looks like a
ball if it looks whatever it looks like
i don't care but if i have some kind of
shape in my hand i can say well i
transferred energy
because i can visualize i can make a
movie of what i'm talking about okay
but if energy is a concept well then we
have a little bit of a problem
so what is energy well if i tell you
people say well bill that's because you
don't like the word energy
so let's let some of the experts out
there tell you what energy is so that
there is no doubt about it okay
here's a fellow uh matt o'dowd
and what he says is what is energy he's
got a video on this you can look it up
in youtube
says he's from pbs okay energy is the
most powerful and useful concept in all
of physics whoa
okay
the most powerful
i believe that that i do believe that
it's got to be so powerful because they
use this word as a joker in a rummy game
they put it everywhere it's like the
word spirit in in religion you know when
you don't know something you say the
spirit
and you fix the problem because it's the
spirit the spirit
you know the soul
uh
thinking mind you know conscience and
they solve everything with that so they
say the spirit and this and the word
energy is a synonym of the word spirit
because they put it anywhere they want
they say oh it's energy and people say
ah now i understand
did they
energy is not a substance he's telling
you
okay energy is a number a quantity
let me repeat that energy is a number it
is not a substance it's a quantity
okay it's a mathematical relationship
uh supposedly he studied physics
somewhere you know uh so
he's got i think a phd in physics that's
why they put him up there so if he
doesn't know what energy is nobody knows
and he's telling you it's a what a
quantity a number that's what it is
can you move a number can you say you
moved a number the number five well you
can move if you take a cardboard and cut
it you know as a five then you can say
move the five but you're not moving the
concept five
you're moving a physical object that
looks like a five that's not a five five
is that concept a mathematical concept
can you move the mathematical concept
five
that's the question so if energy is a
number
you can't say you're going to move a
number
so you cannot talk about the transfer of
a number which is what they're saying
they always say oh we transferred energy
okay that was a good old metal doubt and
here we have another fellow uh
nick lucid and he says what the heck is
energy he's got a video also there you
can look it up
he begins by looking up
the word in the dictionary and of course
what you'll find there is the one from
ordinary speech which they use in
mathematical physics and says it's the
ability or the capacity in fact you'll
find it in every
textbook of physics
mathematical physics that you study
in high school it says energy is the
ability blah blah blah blah blah or the
capacity blah blah blah blah blah blah
okay
and then he tells you very clearly like
good old man he says energy isn't
something tangible
right up front he tells you okay energy
is not a thing in itself good we agree
it is a property of things okay
energy is hidden from view yeah it
better be hidden from you if it's if
it's uh
not a thing and
it's always hidden all concepts are
hidden from you you can't see concepts
energy is a number
so now he said the same thing as good
old man in pbs he says energy is a
number it's a quantity
you can change energy from one type to
another yeah you can change energy to
mass and mass to energy why because
you're changing love into intelligence
and intelligence into love
you're in you're exchanging concepts
that's easy to do
you know you can turn any concept into
any concept you want
the question can you turn you know
an elephant into a tree that's the
question okay so
either you turn an object into an object
or a concept into a concept you know
turning concepts into concepts that's
easy you just do it verbally okay or
with an equation or whatever and so he
says from potential energy which is
location specific into kinetic energy uh
energy of motion whatever that is okay
so how can there be energy of motion
kinetic energy if energy is not a thing
and when it's a potential it's just
located
what do you have what's there i mean if
if energy has location
right
please draw it for me i want to see a
picture of this energy at that location
what is at that location and that's
where they have their contradiction they
tell you it's not something it's not a
thing it's not a substance
but then it has location and it moves
it's got
potential and kinetic energy
that's what they say oh yeah location
meaning a static concept kinetic meaning
motion
energy is the amount of stuff that could
happen
whatever that means what do you mean the
amount of stuff that could happen that's
what this all says apparently he's also
got a degree in physics mathematical
physics okay
and here we have another
person sabine okay
and she says also she's got a video what
is energy
okay what is it uh good old sabine and
she says energy the capacity again looks
it up in the dictionary so that's what i
found in the dictionary
okay no problem so you found that word
in the dictionary it's got a definition
and all he did she did was copy and
paste it like all the others
and says she says it's a property of
things again like uh nicolus
energy is a quantity
all of them say it's a number it's a
quantity so it's not a thing not a
physical thing it's not like a tree or a
rock okay
a theorem gives you a mathematical
procedure to derive what energy is
i'd like to know uh what that
theorem is because uh if you're saying
it's gonna tell you what energy is then
don't tell me that there's a theorem
just draw it for me just show me what it
is because a what
is that which has shape so if you're
going to say that energy is a what and
then you're going to be transferring and
having kinetic and
potential energy you know static and
dynamic energy
you better draw it first so if a theorem
tells you what it is please draw it
says high entropy energy is useless i'm
glad to know that and chemical bonds
store a lot of energy well if it stores
energy like you store food
right or whatever you store you know
boots
clothes
uh
show me the picture don't tell me you
store energy and when a chemical bond
yeah what do you mean store energy so
they use all these euphemisms and people
gotten so used to them after 200 years
300 years right and they just listened
to all that stuff saying oh yeah it
stores energy it transfers you have
kinetic energy you have static energy
you know potential energy and people
just listen to all this nonsense this
language this nonsense language
and they just take it
at face value like saying okay yeah i
understood that
did you and it says energy cannot be
defined if the universe expands
i love that one okay so she has no idea
what energy is because she didn't draw
it she just talks about it and you find
it as capacity
some define it as the ability it doesn't
matter
energy is a verb if anything and
therefore it is a concept it's a dynamic
concept and therefore if it's used as an
object it is irrational no verb turns
into a noun in physics you can't say
running turned into a rock
that's irrational in science and physics
and that's what these people are doing
with the word energy they're saying
energy turned into this thing
that has location that moves you know
that can be transferred etc that's what
they're saying
and so yeah you got to call their bluff
they learned all this by wrote in high
school and college and they just repeat
and they don't even know what they're
saying
so when all the else fails you go to the
nobel prize winners and here you have mr
richard feynman and he says it is
important to realize that in physics
today we have no knowledge of what
energy is yeah because energy is not a
what energy is a concept and so you
can't say
we don't have any idea what what energy
is of course you don't i mean if richard
feynman didn't understand that if he
didn't learn that in high school or even
you know in college
then what did he learn
what kind of physicist is is he if he
cannot tell the difference between a
thing
and a verb
you know
uh how can he say we don't know what
energy is of course you don't know what
energy is because energy is not a what
very simple
and so you wonder you know what his
degree is worth if he doesn't know
something as basic as that
same for this fellow with the science
critic
you know they they they accept all the
stuff by road on the basis of authority
and that's where the problem is when
people become too complacent
with authority and they say oh i'm just
going to accept it on the basis of this
mathematical physicist because he knows
all that math he must know what he's
talking about i'll just i'm just going
to memorize it
copy paste it and tell bill all about it
okay
we have um
some mail we had uh from some people
this week uh this past week and let's go
with that with the fan mail okay here's
the first foul he says
the convention of positive and negative
could correspond to the direction of
vortex rotation
one of these uh electric universers or
etherius or one of those guys and
yeah they think of a vortex as a tornado
of some kind but they never identify the
thing the object so you know i turn
there if they're gonna treat it as a
thing i'm gonna turn it into a
and i guess if he's talking about the
direction i guess uh
the
one that's
you know facing upwards is positive the
one facing downwards is negative
uh you could say the blue one is the
male one always positive right the
female one always negative so it's
pointing downwards i mean
what is a vortex
so they treat these words as physical
objects and they think they're making
sense
no there is no such physical object
called a vortex vortex is
water dr running down your drain that's
what a vortex is so
identifying not the running down the
drain which is what you're thinking of
identify the water then we know what a
vortex is
and again these people talk like that
and they think they're making sense they
say oh it's a vortex like if they knew
what they were talking about and that's
language typical of the um
what is it the
electric universe usually you know could
be ether as some other people you know
okay another fellow says or asks he said
i wrote down the dimensions of an angel
does that mean it's real
well uh
that dimensions of an angel have nothing
to do with dimensions
in other words either you talk i mean
with angel either you talk about the
angel or you talk about the dimensions
of the angel
okay and those are two different things
so and neither one have anything to do
with real
real is what exists and exist has to do
with a physical object in other words a
an object that has location with respect
to the other objects in the universe
and so you know all those words are
one has nothing to do with the other and
this person doesn't even understand that
he's making no sense when he's saying uh
you know angel has dimensions because of
that it exists or is real
you know
none of it follows from the other
okay so that's why we need to define
these terms properly we need to know
what a dimension is we need to know what
an angel is and yes an angel is an
object physical object yeah angel you
can see it there i drew it that's an
angel if you've never seen one there it
is do you see a shape in front of you
well that's what we call an angel some
of them have a little plate on their
head most of them do i think
those are angels and angel is a physical
object always okay
soul
that's a concept but angel angel's a
physical object
and so you know this fellow doesn't
understand that first of all he doesn't
understand the word exists meaning real
meaning
if the angel exists by definition if the
angel has location with respect to all
other objects in the universe
if the angel is like a square you know
or a circle or a triangle which doesn't
have location
then
just like squares triangles and circles
the angel does not exist
very simple so either an angel is an
object right and if if you can draw an
angel it's an object if you see an image
in front of you and if you say the angel
exists the angel had better have
location and that's the first thing you
have to establish okay for the angel
okay so here we have another father says
gravity does not exist another person
they like the word exist
see the word exist belongs exclusively
to physics when people talk about the
word exists whether they know it or not
they
cross the line into physics
otherwise they're talking ordinary
speech which doesn't concern us
it says rate of fall
does depend on both mass and height
okay
rate of fall okay mass in height okay so
far he said nothing he says there's
these two concepts
okay we don't care about that we want to
know
what causes
the object to fall so here we have my
magic wand and it's going to fall there
it is
falls downwards when i let go of it and
you got to tell me why don't tell me
mass don't tell me
uh height don't tell me any of that i
just want to know why what caused it to
fall what physical object came in
contact with the skin
of the
wand that's what you got to identify
that's what you got to illustrate for me
okay you can say uh with particles
hitting it down no problem
you gotta show me what physical object
drew it to the center of the earth to
the to the floor
okay experiments in vacuum have proven
that different elements fall at
different rates
okay
maybe how many beers did you have that
day that's the only question okay
it says n-body systems are unstable for
a greater or equal to three so
heliocentric uh delusions uh delusion
and the universe uh as stuffed into your
uh throats is utter dribble
okay so the fellow doesn't believe in
the heliocentric
universe meaning or solar system meaning
the
uh
sun is at the center of the solar system
the earth goes around i guess he's a
flat earther and believes the opposite
or proposes the opposite theorizes
explains the opposite that it's the
sun that goes around the earth
okay a little balloon little ball that
goes around the earth okay
uh yes even there you go tell me why
what causes the sun to go around the
earth if that's your theory right okay
you got to tell me the cause
why is it up there why does it fall to
earth you know for example i mean you
saw the pencil and the wand all these
things they fall to earth and why
doesn't the sun why is it up there is it
a balloon a hollow balloon that's just
floating air
floating in in air and space why doesn't
the air fall to earth every atom
uh that forms the air why doesn't all
fall to earth
that's what you got to tell me
and then city and buoyancy
explain why objects fall float or rise
in any medium yeah they believe in
density and buoyancy
but they see the
buoyancy is not an explanation
and neither is density okay you got to
tell me what physical object brings
things down
you gotta draw
you gotta do illustrations not not talk
nonsense okay
another follow says philosophy is
structured logic any logic all logic
regarding things that do exist don't
exist can't exist cannot exist
uh okay so the same philosophy is logic
according to him
but
you know that's not philosophy
logic is one thing rationality you know
going from step to step so to speak
uh what's that got to do with philosophy
a lot of serious something else but he
said example your senses tell you that
you see a true wave
a tree waving uh in the distance okay so
the tree is waving in the distance right
you try to create a mental model to
explain why yeah it's called physics
okay so far we've got physic you're
trying to explain why a tree weighs back
and forth okay philosophy tells you it
could be because the tree is alive and
is waving its arms around like a blah
blah blah blah blah no no that's not
philosophy that's known as physics
because
physics is explanations of causes and
mechanisms you're talking about a cause
and mechanism that is not philosophy
neither is just logic okay so
you are an illogical individual if you
think that physical philosophy is just
logic
okay and here we have another following
he says
what is the difference between truth and
fact
aha
good question uh first of all clarify
right science has nothing to do with
fact or with truth
right up front okay so we don't use the
word fact or truth in science those two
words belong strictly to religion
now i'm going to give you uh my version
of what true and fact or truth in fact
are
and why they're not the same again this
is my version okay i'm not concerned
about it if i'm wrong because neither
truth nor fact belong to science or to
physics but a lot of people bring these
two words into
physics into science and so we kind of
have to address the issue and i'm saying
fact is what actually occurred in other
words that's what mother nature has in
her file cabinet you know uh it already
has passed she immediately puts it in
her file cabinet all these things that
happened in the universe okay
maybe it's father universe god the devil
whoever you believe in no problem but
the issue is we don't know exactly what
happened we can only
guess
we have our versions you know the
prosecutor has one version the defense
attorney has another one okay so they
have differences of opinion which is all
there is there okay
and then truth is what you believe
happened okay
so fact is what actually happened which
mother nature filed in her cabinet truth
is more or less you know your version of
what you think happened and that's why
sometimes fact equals truth because you
match what mother nature has in her file
cabinet and uh
until then and even even then even if it
matches since we cannot be sure that
that's exactly what happened we call it
a statement of the facts in other words
assumption in other words hypothesis
okay that's what a hypothesis is it's
just a statement of the facts of what
you think or how you think something
happened okay it doesn't mean that is
the way it happened it's how you think
it happened and you're going to build on
that assumption right because you're
just going to present the initial scene
there and then you're going to explain
what caused it to happen okay which is a
little different than just presenting
some of the like i explained earlier you
know the uh
fact that um
you say well something hard
probably
let's assume right that something hard
broke the window that's just an
assumption so far i haven't talked about
the theory that i'm proposing i'm just
saying we're making an assumption that
something hard broke the window
and then i say what was a dog it was a
baseball bat a crowbar or whatever
that's the theory
another fellow says or ass
says the phone says bill
tension is not a force yeah that's what
i said okay so he's repeating what i
said tension is not a force so he asks
what is a force
okay and this is out of the wikipedia
says force an influence that can change
the motion of an object
okay
that's about as close as you'll get and
uh so
this is my definition down there again
we don't use the word force in science
in physics okay
we use objects so when we talk about a
force we talk about pull or push and we
identify the object that's doing the
pulling or the pushing you need to
identify the object you cannot say a
force
uh blew the house down no it's got to be
the air or some some physical object
okay air is a physical object yes
and um so it's a physical contact that
induces motion
okay that's what a force is
okay so you can use it in that sense
and there's only two kinds of forces
it's either push or pull
in the religion of mathematical physics
they have four forces at least so far i
don't know how many more there's some
are inventing some more out there but
they
invented the
strong force the weak force
electromagnetism and gravity which
the electric universe says all is just
one force okay great
but uh
so the gluons the strong force that's a
pull force because it pulls two quarks
together
and the weak force is a push force
because it
it pushes out things out of the atom
so
again uh i don't know what four forces
they have there's only two forms of
contact we can imagine physical
forms of contact that induce motion and
that's push and pull
okay in in opposition to that we have
tension tension is not a force like i
said up there okay
tension physical contact that does not
produce motion
and there you have the two
people doing tug of war okay
and no one wins the tug of war they're
completely tied
not one guy moved an inch in any
direction backward or forward that's
called tension
no one wins the tug of war if one wins
the tug of war tension suddenly turns
into force
okay it could be push or pull in this
case usually it's pull right tug of war
that's why it's called tug
okay but otherwise you know um it's very
straightforward uh there's only
push-pull in physics okay and science
uh push-pull and if no one wins the
toggle four we call it tension
very simple
okay here we have another five he says
if a field is only the mathematics of
math magicians why can we observe fields
interacting with matter
you can observe you can see with your
two eyes the fields
jesus christ you've got
great eyeballs here
i envy your your eyesight guy okay
a field is an energy
interacting with matter
well
energy as we just covered a little while
ago is just a concept and you're saying
field is just another concept which is
an energy
so so far we've got nothing in front of
us we have two concepts and you can see
a concept
man not even poor old god can see a
concept but here you're telling me that
you can see a kind you can observe
whatever that means you know observe
fields
how many beers did you get yeah
anyways uh here's uh just in case the
wikipedia says field in physic for the
purposes of physics okay a mathematical
construct for what analysis of remote
effects
so it's a mathematical whatever
okay and also from the wikipedia second
definition there field a quantity
quantity numbers math you know that has
a value for each point in space and time
so it's a concept there's no such
physical object that is a quantity
no quantity is a is an object so yeah
you if you can observe a quantity okay
unless you have another notion of what a
field is i wish you would draw a field
standalone field would do you know no
other object in in your field of view i
just want to see what a field is
okay and uh so if you can draw a field
or point to a field out there you know
stand alone field love it bring it bring
a mock-up
of a field to the uh
to the conference so that we can all see
it you know put in the center of the
room we can all walk around it and see
the field stand-alone field is it
floating in the air somewhere you know i
mean i don't know
let me know i'm really curious to find
out what a field is okay
uh someone says is the fixed speed of
light the tool employed to measure the
distance of a light year and the answer
is yes again we don't measure anything
in science we don't
really use the light year in physics we
have no use for it except you know to
say
something is far away
okay so we don't care how long it takes
to travel in this case light years
really a measure of distance the
distance traveled by light in one year
and yeah they use 300 000 kilometers
per second or 299 et cetera et cetera
meters per second okay
uh
that's the speed of light that they use
that's what
that's the most accurate uh value that
they have today for the speed of light
in science and physics we say it's
fast
that's how accurate it is okay very
accurate
swift
that's what we say that's how fast light
is it's fast
quick
okay and um so uh is um
uh so so we look at the word light year
okay let your distance that light
travels in a vacuum in one julian year
and that's what you'll find in the
wikipedia so yeah the answer is yes it's
light traveling in one year that's
that's um
known as a light year and again it's a
measure of distance not of uh
speed or time or anything like that
okay another fellow says
see what he has to say it says
what is the mechanism by which the atom
this is under the rope model eats the
rope and presumably
uh pumps it out to retain uh the proper
size
could an element become different
element by eating too much rope
well let's answer the first question the
second question first and that is no uh
elements change only with the addition
or subtraction of more protons neutrons
and electrons or or
fewer you know more or fewer of those so
uh
more rope doesn't change uh anything
okay so um just by reeling in
uh it the rope doesn't stay within the
atom okay and that's something he's got
to understand that that goes to the
first question the first question there
you see an illustration of it
uh an atom doesn't swallow
the rope and become bigger which is the
notion this fella has in his mind that's
not what the atom does the atom slides
through the ropes
and the ropes open up okay and that
momentarily forms
part of the atom and then the atom
continues and opens up the next one and
goes to the next one and so on down the
line okay so what's happening is
the atom is sliding through a pair of
ropes which are sliding around it in
fact one goes
above which is forms the electron shell
the other one goes through the center
which forms the proton and that's our
model maybe someone comes up with a
better model than that but that's the
model we have right now okay that's the
one we propose
and there are a couple people that are
working on that and have different
versions of that so that's good you know
that's up to them if they have a
different version i'd like to hear it
okay
uh anyways here's another phone he says
what he says if you take a picture of
fire you have a picture yeah
uh the picture is not fire
okay
it is but let's get to that in a second
a picture is a representation i guess a
representation of fire okay fire water
gas no shape
objects must be defined by borders which
persist in time
well he's got all of them wrong
essentially okay uh yeah you can take a
picture of fire and there i took a
picture of fire in other words
uh that's fire
snapshot drawing whatever you want to
call it it's a still image of fire
okay
what we're talking about is the word
fire
okay the word fire
is not taking a picture of fire any more
than taking a picture of plasma is
plasma okay when you take a picture
you're just you have a shape because you
do have a shape there
i mean do you see something in front of
you fire has that fire has shape that's
a static image of fire but that's not
fire because the word fire the word fire
the word
fire
involves motion
there is no such thing as fire without
motion fire is a process it's a process
of combustion
you're oxidizing something
that's called fire
so you can't say fine i took a snapshot
of fire yes you can take a snapshot of
fire
and you can call that fire for the
contextually okay you say look i'm going
to illustrate fire in a single frame but
that's not the what the word fire stands
for the word fire stands for a process
that's why fire is not a physical entity
despite that in a snapshot it has shape
under a different context
did i get through to your
brain hopefully and yes um fire water
and gas do have shape there you see
liquid has shape and the word liquid or
for example water doesn't have to move
water does not the word water does not
include motion okay we don't say when we
look at when we say chair we're not
thinking of motion we're just pointing
and saying
chair is a static
concept in other words it's an object
okay it's just a shape in front of you
you don't say the chair has to move in
order to for the word chair to be valid
that's what i'm saying
and the same with any liquid liquid
stands still okay so i can point to gas
to well i can put the gas to water
to air i don't have to have the air
moving in order for it to be air the
word air the definition of the word air
okay
air can be a single blob
okay and that we can call that air
because it doesn't have to move fire
does have to move in order for it to be
fired because the word fire embodies
motion like the word plasma embodies
motion there is no such thing as plasma
standing still
because the word plasma means ionized
atom
atoms plural okay ionized ionized means
something is happening
that's why plasma is not a physical
object because
something is happening inside the word
plasma we're talking about the word
plasma the word plasma represents
ionization the word fire represents
combustion the word gas does not
represent any motion whatsoever the word
liquid does not represent any motion
whatsoever it doesn't embody it doesn't
it doesn't have the word it has any
motion inside it inside the word
okay you don't need the motion to have
liquids or gases
okay so that's the issue there uh i hope
someone understood out there because
they confused
uh for example someone the other day
confused clouds but the cloud is
changing from one second to the other
i don't care the word cloud does not
embody motion
the word cloud has no uh
ingredient called motion in it
the word fire does the word plasma does
the word cloud does not the word gas
does not the word liquid or any liquid
like water or
oil or whatever i don't need motion
inside the word oil
or water or any other liquid for that
matter
okay the word river does river means
something is flowing
okay like electricity electricity
already embodies motion you can't you
can't have you can take a picture maybe
of electricity but that's not
electricity electricity is already
defined as something in motion it's
already in body
embodies motion
okay so that's the issue
and i don't know these people have the
brains to understand that
okay so here it is another last one
fellow says it is physically impossible
for each atom in the universe to be
connected to every other atom in the
universe
he says it's physically impossible okay
my
my proposal my assumption my hypothesis
is that all atoms in the universe are
interconnected he's saying that's
impossible why
the primary reason it uh in uh the
insane and town entanglement from those
gazillions of ropes what is he thinking
about he's thinking about tangibility
he's thinking about touch he's saying oh
all the ropes they have to be tangled
because they touch each other
an object is not that which has can be
seen or touched
an object is that which has shape
the rope the electromagnetic rope that
we propose has shape it cannot be seen
or touched it doesn't have the ability
of touch that we have in our macro world
people say well how convenient bill you
you really uh put some properties that
uh just uh
you know like ad hoc
well see the problem first is that
quantum mechanics does the same thing
but nobody questions that over there you
know two particles can be at the same
place nobody says anything about that
that's one issue but then the other
issue is that i gotta represent what
mother nature has
so if if i'm gonna say that the ropes
have touch
then all these ropes should be tangled
and that's not what mother nature has
out there so i wouldn't be able to
explain her world if i included touch
the ability to touch the rope to be able
to touch another rope
if it would be able to touch another
rope yeah we would have problem mother
nature wouldn't be able to run her her
shop
so yeah we have to make it with
intangibility you have to represent what
mother nature has and the one i'd like
to show is one one of them is the rope
you know here's the rope okay now you
can see this one you can touch this one
this one okay because this is not the
rope mother nature uses this is just a
configuration
the architecture of what she uses it has
shape it has this shape only shape is
the only thing that is in common that's
why we call it a rope okay that's the
only reason it doesn't have the same
properties as this throat you can't see
or touch it
why because the ropes mother nature uses
do not have the ability to see and touch
you don't have the ability to see and
touch them it doesn't have the ability
to touch essentially that's the main one
ropes can't touch ropes
okay and so you you have to get rid of
this touch thing because again the
definition
is what's wrong it's what's irrational
the definition that we have today that
everything that an object is that which
you can see your touch okay that's where
the problem is and here's another uh
example you know here we have uh two
magnets okay and you can see that they
stick together okay
and can you see or touch anything in
here okay and the answer is no you can't
you can't see or touch
what mother nature is using there
and so you're going to say there's
nothing here between these two magnets
why do they stick together
magic is this
is this uh
a you know this magnetic field that you
call there what is that
is that mediated by no substance no no
thing
and so hopefully there's something here
because otherwise you're doing black
magic you're saying this happens by
remote control and there's nothing here
in between them
so you're doing black magic
and so we're saying no there is
something here that you cannot see or
touch so when i say the rope cannot be
seen or touched
i'm
imitating what mother nature is doing if
i said that the rope can be seen or
touched you say okay let's go to the
lab and let's find out if i can see or
touch it with a machine or a robot or
whatever you can't see or touch it
get get over it
you can't see or touch it ropes cannot
be touched ropes cannot touch each other
and as long as you can come to
up to speed with that you'll be okay
then you'll be able to explain a lot of
stuff in the universe but as long as you
think that an object is that which you
can see or touch and you talk about
entangled ropes and how can we see the
robe and why can't we touch the rope
then then you got a problem you got the
problem because you're not imitating
mother nature's universe you gotta
explain her universe not the one you got
in your tiny
brain okay okay so we'll see you on
sunday next coming sunday we'll see you
then bye-bye